Film Courage: Should a screenwriter start
designing the movie poster before the script
is written?
Scott Kirkpatrick: No, I don’t think so.
I mean I mentioned that in the Writing for
the Greenlight [Scott’s book] because that’s
how we did it.
We already had the established connection
and track record of being able to pre-sell
movies and to produce them and deliver them
and have them actually meet the expectations
of what we promise to deliver and we had a
whole marketing department that knew how to
create poster work specifically for the movie
buying audience.
You can usually tell when an indie producer
has drafted their own artwork versus when
it’s done by a company that’s is used
to selling into the movie space because it
just has a completely different look.
It’s not a marketable, punchy, pushy-type
poster.
Not that there is anything wrong with it.
It’s just that it’s not the type of stuff
that attracts the buyers from all over the
world or things of that nature.
They get redesigned and redesigned throughout
the whole process.
I think the screenwriter shouldn’t worry
about the stuff they’re not going to be
in a position (especially starting out) where
they have to presell their project to buyers.
They’re selling themselves…they are not
even selling their script really…they are
selling their talent to write.
So they shouldn’t have to focus on the marketing
components of creating artwork, they should
focus on making sure that they’re producing
a library of work, a portfolio that they can
showcase that’s ideally all of the same
type of genre so they can just be the go-to
screenwriter who can deliver that type of
film quickly and reliably.
Just as I am saying, we would sell movies
(pre-sell) movies off of the poster, people
would pay us and pre-buy them because they
knew we could deliver them.
There’s a lot of companies that try to pre-sell
that fail.
I’ve worked with ones that were very successful
because we’ve had the track record of being
able to reliably deliver on time good quality
products.
That’s what the screenwriter wants to do
just from a writing perspective.
Here’s my showcase of what I can do, this
proves a track record.
If you give me the opportunity you can guarantee
and trust that I am going to get it done correctly
the first time.
Film Courage: So why do you think those other
titles failed?
What was the reason?
I mean you said that there were others that
tried the same approach.
Scott Kirkpatrick: Look pre-sales is this
really cool, fun idea of like “You know,
my idea is going to be so great, I’m just
going to get 20 countries to jump on board
and buy it.”
You really have to know how the pre-sale process
works, who the buyers are at these companies
that are willing to invest that money.
You have to already produced a decent amount
of content that’s going to kind of prove
the fact that you know what you’re doing
and you can deliver movies on time that are
under budget or on budget that meet all the
technical specifications of that specific
country.
It’s a delicate process and it’s not easy
to do and not all companies do it.
There’s a lot of companies that have no
interest in even trying it.
But the idea of selling a movie off of a poster
really only today happens at the pre-sale
stage and not every company does pre-sales.
Big studios, they will come out and basically
say this is our slate.
Independent companies, we have to go build
those relationships because we don’t have
output deals with everybody.
We don’t have guaranteed buys in the majority
of countries the way studios do.
So there are companies that try to do that
and have to be very…they have to have a
good reputation for being able to already
accomplish what they are selling themselves
to be able to do.